the jurogan experience
power is so scary like that kind of
power the the power and also the
influence and sort of cronyism like
being deeply attached to the criminal
justice system for many many years over
there being respected and being a part
of this investigative world where
they're all the cops and they're all
just like they know each other and you
know they look out for each other
the fact that they didn't change their
story once they had all the dna evidence
of that rudy guy and then it was all
over they didn't go okay we've made a
mistake and instead they doubled down
and not only that but
didn't go after him for the murder well
they did but they didn't convict him of
the murder i should say so what are they
convicted of so they convicted him of
her rape
because it was only his dna that was
found inside of her body
and they convicted him of conspiracy to
commit murder so basically taking part
in a murder but not being the one to
actually plunge the knife but this was a
fabrication
by the
this is the prosecutor's idea that he
was there with rafaeli and that you guys
held her down yes so they say that
the scenario that my
my prosecutor painted and he painted a
few different scenarios because he
couldn't really like his imagination was
going wild and there wasn't a lot of
actual
obviously there wasn't any evidence to
support any of them but he kept thinking
okay it's it's near it's the day after
halloween so maybe it's a satanic sex
ritual we know that there's some kind of
sex thing involved we know that amanda
is like well we know we know that amanda
has sex with people so she's probably a
sexually obsessed person and meredith
looked down on her for being a sexually
obsessed person so what is likely to
have happened in his brain is that i was
hanging out with rafael and rudy
meredith comes home she starts scolding
me for my bad morals and then i'm like
you know what [ __ ] we're gonna rape you
and kill you that's that's his scenario
and
it's it's so unfortunate on so many
levels because it's
i mean it says more about him than it
says about anyone else that he would
imagine that that's just how people
react to each other and this was not his
initial idea though right was this his
initial idea i mean his initial idea was
that i was involved somehow he didn't
know how but he thought that i was
involved somehow i knew something i was
covering up for someone and that's why
he interrogated me for 53 hours over
five days um which is really scary that
they can do that right it's like
you can get someone to say a lot of
things if you can get alone with them in
a room and scare the [ __ ] out of them
and
and just torture them well i'm glad you
you know that because like a lot of
people don't know that you can get
people to crack oh absolutely like
that's
it's people crack when they get pulled
over by the cops for speeding oh yeah
people crack for all kinds of things
they crack if they have a joint in their
glove box
people crack yeah you know when when
authority is scaring you coming down you
and in your case actually hit you a
couple times
there's and you're 20. yeah right like
20. your brain isn't even fully formed
my brain isn't fully formed my friend
had just been murdered i was alone in a
foreign country and people were people
who i was entrusting my life and safety
to were screaming at me that
i was wrong that i was never going to
see my family again that i was super
traumatized that i had i had seen
something so horrible that i must have
just completely blocked it out and
here's and and here's a scenario that
would explain that look you have a text
message from your boss patrick lumumba
you must have met him that night you
must have seen him murder meredith just
admit it just admit it remember remember
remember they kept telling me like the
gross thing about it was they kept
telling me to remember they didn't even
tell me to like admit it they were
telling me that i just couldn't remember
it and i had to remember or else i was
never going to see my family again jesus
so were you thinking that you just had
to tell them whatever they wanted to
hear just so you could get out of there
honestly i started to question my own
sanity i started to believe them that i
must have witnessed something horrible
and i just couldn't remember it and
that's the only explanation for why they
would treat me that way how long did
that take before you think you started
questioning your sanity
um
so
i was you know a few hours into that
final interrogation that was in the
middle of the night i was not prepared
to be interrogated at all because
honestly they didn't even call me in
that night they called my boyfriend
rafael
but i was staying with him and i was
afraid to be alone at home because a
murder was on the loose and so i went
with him and i was waiting in the um
in the lobby like by the elevator
waiting for him to come out from
questioning and then they brought me in
um and just
went on and on and on um
and so
i cracked eventually so the thing that
cracked me too was they brought in
an interpreter right someone who
actually spoke english because for a
long time i was just talking to people
in italian and i was worried that i
couldn't i wasn't even comprehensible i
thought that the reason why they were
yelling at me was because i was doing
something wrong like i just wasn't
explaining myself correctly and i'm like
how fluid were you fluent were you i
mean i had been there for like five
weeks so i was and you took italian
before i take italian for a year before
so i i was about as fluent as i like to
say
i had about the fluency of a 10 year old
but i think that that's even generous
because i could speak in certain tenses
my vocabulary was totally limited though
so there were limited things that i
actually had the words to say
and i remember even when i um
shortly after i was interrogated and
signed the statements that they had
written up for me i they finally stopped
yelling at me they left me alone i had a
moment to just like be off to the side
quiet to myself and i was like oh my god
what just happened everything is wrong
this is all wrong i need to tell them
that it's all wrong and i'd like i can't
just go up in front of a jury right now
and say this is the person who did it i
saw him do it like i don't actually
remember that and i told them i need to
tell you i need to tell you and they
were like no you'll remember don't worry
about it like we don't we don't need to
talk anymore you'll remember just stay
over there and keep remembering and i
was like no i'm not remembering i'm not
remembering and eventually i asked them
like please give me a piece of paper
because they weren't listening to me so
i wrote on this piece of paper i'm so
confused they were yelling at me like i
don't i don't i can't actually testify
to this and i gave it to them and i was
like here's a gift because i didn't have
the word for like here's my
recantation right i was just like i'm
giving this to you i need you to hear me
and they were like okay whatever we're
taking you to jail actually they didn't
even tell me they were taking me to jail
they they were telling me that i was
being taken to a holding place for my
own protection and that i was an
important witness
so they didn't tell you that you were
being taken to jail because you were
one of the people they were accusing no
i was already in prison before i was
ever actually told you are being
you are suspected for the killing of
meredith kircher
i was already in prison
how long had you known this meredith
girl for
a few weeks
and you'd met her just because you'd all
moved there at the same time yeah yeah i
was sharing a place together yeah so she
had moved in
before me
um but
it was basically there were two rooms to
let in this little house that was right
next to the university and we both
happened to
pick a flyer
um
and
did you guys hang out a lot did you know
her well was she a good friend or she
just someone you lived with
um she was like a budding friend like we
definitely hung out we would go to pizza
together i remember we went to like
there's this famous chocolate festival
that's in perugia where they would like
take huge refrigerator-sized
blocks of chocolate and like carve them
um which is super cool i'm very into
that and we would go and check that out
together
but we weren't like the best of friends
like she had a friend group of other
young women from
great britain that she hung out with a
lot more than she hung out with me
but that isn't to say that we didn't go
out dancing together or go out to dinner
together we definitely did that the
moment you found out that she had been
murdered
what was that like
um
it's
confusing because
i knew that something was wrong as soon
as i found when i came home and i found
that there was a window broken into and
meredith wasn't answering her phone but
i didn't understand what was wrong i
didn't i didn't know and when the police
came in and broke down her door and
everyone started screaming
i didn't see into her room i never
actually saw her body and so i didn't
know what was going on i didn't know if
that was meredith in the room in fact i
remember at the first thing that
philomena one of my roommates started
yelling was a foot a foot and i was like
oh my god is there like a severed foot
in meredith's room like i don't know
what's going on she's philamena is
hysterical and i don't know what's going
on everyone's yelling in italian
speaking really quickly i don't
understand so i actually was relying on
rafael to translate for me like what is
going on he was like i don't know let me
let me figure it out and we were all
like shoved out of the house and finally
someone is like
it's meredith it's meredith and she's
dead and i was like oh my god
like it was outside of the house that
someone was telling me she's her body
was in there
and someone told me that there was all
this blood um i remember not actually
knowing like how she had died until i
went to the police office and i asked i
was like being questioned and one of the
police officers was like
and so like i sort of learned
over the course of that day
these the
the details of it
but i didn't fully understand like what
had really happened like as far as i
knew
you know
she she some
i mean it was clear that there was a
break-in like the window had been broken
into
one of it was philamena's room all of
her stuff was all over the place it
wasn't clear to me what had happened
though and it wasn't until over the
course of that whole day and piecing
together what i was hearing that i
understood the gravity of the situation
that she had been sexually assaulted
that she had been stabbed to death that
it was a struggle um it was all
it was all like
i remember the first thought and it's a
guilty thought that i had
i remember thinking
thank god i wasn't home
because
that could have been me
and a part of me like over time felt
really guilty about that thought because
i thought maybe if i was home and there
had been two of us
maybe the outcome would have been
different maybe we would have been able
to fend him off together
but
here's you know an athletic guy wielding
a knife i'm not sure that we would have
and maybe i would have been dead too
so
it's kind of a thought that comes back
to mind a lot when i think about this
and how fortuitous it was um that i just
happened to be
in this like brand new romance and
hanging out with my new boyfriend all
the time every waking moment that i
could
and
that's what happened
it's hard for me to imagine
the jolt
of
a 20 year old life where you are
overseas
going to school
involved in this new romantic
relationship and then
out of nowhere
boom you're a suspect in a murder
yeah well and what's interesting is i
didn't know like i didn't know that i
was a suspect is like the boom for me
was
someone close to me just
died and that could have been me and
now what
and then it was all those things that
piled on they get piling on
yeah
and then you know i'm in jail i'm
thinking oh my god this is all just a
horrible misunderstanding like that i'm
sure they're going to figure it out
sometime
i remember like the first two years of
my imprisonment i was convinced that it
was all just a big misunderstanding and
somebody would figure it out
and i was convinced i was i was
convinced that
there was no
possible way that people could actually
believe that i was involved
like that
even just not because of it's me but
because there wasn't any evidence there
like it was so patently obvious to me
that like this this idea of me this foxy
noxie character that was being
constructed in the courtroom this
luciferina
like this idea of a person was obviously
made up it was so obvious to me
and yet
and and yet it seemed like the italian
media just ran with it though oh yeah
yeah and that was one of the
the big sort of
regrets that my especially my family had
was at the very beginning
um they were advised to not speak to the
media at all because they were just
going to make a field day of it there
was you know in the same way that there
was never going once i was accused there
was never going to be anything that i
could do to prove my innocence in the
eyes of people
my lawyers were also worried that there
was nothing my family could say but that
would not be twisted and and turned into
something that would just
further fuel the scandal mongering
and
what that meant was there was a void
there was a void in which
who i was my very identity could be
reconstruct or constructed out of
total fantasy that was the only thing
that was
that the only reason why it was being
constructed was to further this scandal
and to sell more papers
like that that was the reason why
the
it wasn't the public interest of the
story that kept the sun in in britain
reporting on this case like they were
they were reporting like reporting on
whether or not i ate pizza like the days
leading up to my arrest like it's just
selling it's just selling papers
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify